meilleur maire du ballet le sénat comme
vous ne l'avez jamais entendue
nous y sommes le saint des saints le
coeur battant de la démocratie
permettez-moi une requête avant de
poursuivre le récit amis visiteurs ici
point d'arrêt avance et le lieu ne
tolère pas de répit encore que ne nous
mentons points il faut bien parfois
quelques pauses
28 octobre 1859 1h du matin tout à coup
une alarme retentit au feu l'hémicycle
brûle pendant toute la nuit les pompiers
de paris et des deux militaires et
d'habitants du quartier vont se battre
contre les flammes dix pompes puise dans
le bassin du jardin et dans les
réservoirs de la cuisine du palais
aucun blessé n est à déplorer mais la
coupole de la salle des séances n'y
survivra pas à 5 heures le treuil du
lustre en fonte tombe il traverse le
plancher
déjà affaibli par le poids de l'eau et
des matériaux qui le jonchent il
s'effondre de cet incendie on ne sut
jamais vraiment la cause hormis
certaines peintures le décor de la salle
fut restaurer à l'identique c'est qu'ici
la continuité règne pas loin de 200 ans
qu'on débat examine apostrophe
questionne vote contrôle des centaines
des milliers d'heures de débats dont la
succession des lois sont le souvenir
faire la loi ou plutôt l'examiner dit on
ici vous vous en doutez l'exercice est
codifié eh bien monsieur l'huissier
dites nous quel rituel en cours dans
cette assemblée faire la loi comme vous
dites c'est un long et important
processus le texte de loi qu'ils soient
d'origine gouvernementale ou
parlementaire est d'abord décortiqué
puis travaillé par la commission dont il
ressort son étude dans l'hémicycle c'est
l'étape finale le président de séance
depuis son siège sur le plateau dirige
organise les interventions et le débat
il y a plusieurs catégories de loi
prenons l'exemple d'un projet de loi le
président ouvre la séance dite publique
puis après d'éventuelles communications
annonce ce texte à l'ordre du jour la
discussion générale commence et la
parole est donnée en premier aux
ministres en charge du texte il monte à
la tribune de l'orateur c'est celle qui
se trouve juste en dessous du président
après que le ministre ait présenté le
texte d'autres orateurs se succèdent à
la tribune
rapporteur présidents de commissions
puis sénatrices et sénateurs des
différents groupes politiques mais aussi
membre de la commission pour des temps
de parole préalablement définis vient
ensuite l'étude article par article des
modifications apportées sur le texte on
les appelle les un moment se tient bien
du verbe amendée qui veut dire améliorer
chaque amendement donc fait l'objet d'un
vote le plus souvent à main levée et
parfois par scrutin public à la fin une
fois que tout le texte a été examiné le
président donne la parole aux différents
parlementaires qui souhaite expliquer
leur vote et le sénat se prononce sur
l'ensemble du texte
mission de loi est définitivement adopté
et vous que diable faites-vous dans ses
travers et bien justement s'il y a des
huissiers c'est pour qu'aucun petit
diable ne vienne perturber le débat
notre tenue vestimentaire est très
spécifique elle permet à tous de nous
reconnaître nous sommes en quelque sorte
les gardiens de l'hémicycle c'est pour
cela qu'en dehors des sénatrices et des
sénateurs nous sommes les seuls à
pouvoir nous déplacer dans la salle des
séances
nous assurerons une police courtoise que
chacun respecte seules les personnes
habilitées peuvent entrer dans
l'hémicycle un exemple les
collaborateurs du ministre que l'on
appelle commissaire du gouvernement
doivent se présenter muni de l'ordre de
créer ministériel mais notre rôle ne se
limite pas à cela il est très vaste nous
renseignons les parlementaires nous
distribuons des messages documents
nécessaires principalement les
amendements nous organisons le scrutin
public qu'il soit dans l'hémicycle ou de
façon plus solennels dans la salle des
conférences
quand il s'agit bien sûr d'un vote sur
l'ensemble d'un texte important nous
avons bien d'autres missions notamment
protocolaire internes ou externes au
palais du luxembourg et nous
accompagnons fréquemment les délégations
du sénat lors de célébrations
officielles merci cher monsieur quant à
vous chers amis saviez vous que chaque
séance est publique car tout citoyen
doit pouvoir connaître et mieux
comprendre les décisions prises au nom
de la nation